frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen mitnehmen aufbauhilfe gesetz
geraten wir heute auch über wichtige
änderungen im infektionsschutzgesetz das
parlamentarische die parlamentarischen
beratungen der letzten tage haben uns
allen koalitionen opposition viel
abverlangt ich möchte aber auch noch mal
unmissverständlich klarstellen das
beratungsverfahren war straff es ist
jedoch ordnungsgemäß durchgeführt worden
und herr gesundheitsminister sparen
werden sie gleich der spd gefolgt hätte
das parlamentarische verfahren schon
lange geordnet vor der sommerpause krieg
wollen und abgeschlossen werden können
diese randbemerkungen vorweg gestellt
möchte ich nun auf die wesentlichen
änderungen im infektionsschutzgesetz ein
team in der öffentlichkeit kontrovers
diskutiert wird das auskunftsrecht von
arbeitgebern über den corona impfstatus
von beschäftigten die einen fordern mehr
den anderen geht es nicht weit genug wir
erweitern mit dem vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf aber aus gutem grund den
kleister einrichtungen in denen von den
beschäftigten eine auskunft über den
corona in bzw
ki moon status verlangt werden kann denn
es waren niemanden zu erklären warum
dies zum beispiel in krankenhäusern in
arztpraxen halt langer zeit
selbstverständlich ist in der ambulanten
und stationären pflege aber nicht
kitas und schulen jetzt ebenfalls mit
einzubeziehen ist für mich als
gesundheitspolitikerin angesichts der
steigenden infektionszahlen
beitrittsland
eben gar nicht schützen können und
jugendlichen wirklich das gebot der
stunde denn dort denn dort wo hunden
schutzbedürftige menschen sehr nach
zusammenkommen muss in der partie
besondere vorsicht gelten und für die
sicherstellung des infektionsschutz es
ist es sowohl für beschäftigte als auch
für die zu betreuenden wichtig dass der
arbeitgeber in dem ein starkes kind nur
dann kann der infektionsschutz im
betrieb sowohl für beschäftigte als auch
für die zu betreuenden optimal
sichergestellt werden für die spd ist es
aber ganz klar
gesundheitsdaten sind sehr sensible
daten sie unterliegen einem besonderen
schutz und deshalb müssen regelungen zur
offenlegung dieser angaben die absolute
gut begründete auswechseln
meine prüferinnen und bürger liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind noch
mitten in der kantine
allerdings hat die wohl vertraute sieben
tage ins events mit steigender info der
an aussagekraft bezüglich der belastung
des krankenhaus sektors verloren
kollegin grundlage stoppen sein
gestaltungen inzwischen frage bezüglich
der belastung des krankenhaussektor sehr
verloren es ist deshalb nur konsequent
für notwendige infektionsschutz
maßnahmen stärker auf die
hospitalisierung gerade abzustellen sie
wird der neue leitwert die inzidenz
bleibt aber wichtiger frühindikator
sowohl was die infektions dynamik als
auch die verteilung in den altersgruppen
angeht sie wird bei den infektionsschutz
maßnahmen genauso wie die impfquote oder
intensiv belegung weiterhin
berücksichtigt werden müssen
konkrete bundeseinheitliche
schwellenwerte wird es allerdings nicht
mehr geben diese können die länder unter
berücksichtigung ihrer
versorgungskapazitäten künftig selbst
festlegen der kolleginnen und kollegen
ist es gut dass wir heute diese
wichtigen ehrungen im infektionsschutz
vorlieben diese regelungen sind
ausgewogen sie sind notwendig und sie
sind richtig aber ich sage auch besser
noch als die erfassung desinfektions
geschehens ist es die kobik infektion
überhaupt nicht zuzulassen über 54
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
sich schon für eine impfung entschieden
eine gute entscheidung aber um sicher
durch herbst und winter zu kommen müssen
sich noch mehr entscheiden und ich
appelliere deshalb appelliere deshalb an
alle zögerlichen zweifler ständiger
setzen sie sich noch einmal intensiv mit
den impfungen auseinander sprechen sie
mit ihren arzt und ihrer ersten neue
studien zeigen erneut die wirksamkeit in
sicherheit der impfstoffe in der
altersgruppe 18 bis 59 heißt das ganz
konkret für von 90 prozentiger schutz
vor hospitalisierung 97 prozentiger
schutz vor intensivbehandlung
hundertprozentiger schutz vor einem
deutlichen krankheitsverlauf also lassen
sie sich im schützen sie ihr leben und
ihr eigens unendlichen dank und bleiben
sie gesund
sabine liegt man mit einem appell sich
impfen zu lassen solange das oder sofern
das noch nicht geschehen ist ich muss
noch nachtragen diebe zuschauerinnen
liebe zuschauer sie haben sicherlich
schon bemerkt die im präsidium hat der
vorsitz dieser sitzung gewechselt ist
jetzt die vize präsidentin gestellt von
der fraktion die linke und petra pau sie
hat wolfgang kubicki abgelöst aus gutem
grund denn der wird nämlich gleich in
der laufenden debatte noch retten
zunächst aber rüdiger lucassen von der
fdp-fraktion
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die flut im westen deutschlands ist
zweifelsfrei eine jahrhundertkatastrophe
ich selbst habe schäden in diesem ausmaß
vorher noch nie mit eigenen augen
gesehen
meine wohnung liegt in der altstadt von
bad münstereifel direkt an der erft das
haus hat standgehalten ist aber
einsturzgefährdet am samstag nach der
flut konnten meine frau und ich unseren
hausstand retten ob und wann wir wieder
in unser heim zurückkehren können wissen
wir nicht eines weiß ich aber gewiss
wenn das eigene leben betroffen ist
blickt man klarer auf die dinge als aus
dem fenster eine staatslimousine
unseren verlust teile ich mit tausenden
landsleuten in der region viele haben
noch weitaus mehr verloren dass wir mehr
als 180 menschen sind in den fluten ums
leben gekommen
180 menschen die in ihren wohnstuben
saßen oder sachen aus dem keller holen
wollten mit dem auto aus der tiefgarage
fuhren oder sogar auf der straße auf dem
weg nach hause fortgerissen wurden 180
menschen die jetzt tot sind und die
trotz der tatsache dass sie tot sind
einen anspruch haben einen anspruch auf
die frage nach der verantwortung für
ihren tod in nordrhein westfalen hat die
flut ein staatsversagen offengelegt der
katastrophe bevölkerungsschutz von bund
und landesregierung hat in gigantischem
ausmaß
versagt
alarmierungen des europäischen
hochwasser
warnsystems wurden ignoriert
sirenen wurden nicht aktiviert die
bedrohten dörfer und städte wurden viel
zu spät
evakuiert das hat menschenleben gekostet
das staatsversagen ist das eine
das andere ist er inzwischen
kult reflex der politik dieses versagen
auf den klimawandel zu schieben ja
klima wandelt sich schon immer ja der
band mensch muss besser mit der natur
umgehen alles richtig aber für den
hochwasserschutz für rückhaltebecken für
aufforstung für sirenen digitale wahn
systeme sind die regierungen in bund und
ländern zuständig und nicht das klima
der schutz der bevölkerung ist die
kernaufgabe des staates und damit die
erste pflicht eines ministerpräsidenten
herr laschet hätte die menschen warnen
und evakuieren müssen das hat er nicht
getan herr laschet hätte für eine
infrastruktur zum schutz der dörfer und
städte sorgen müssen das hat er nicht
getan herr laschet hat die menschen in
nordrhein westfalen im stich gelassen er
hat die bevölkerung nicht geschützt
meine damen und herren in all dem
versagen der politik war auch ein
lichtblick zu sehen und das sind die
menschen in unserem land was ich in den
tagen nach der flut in meiner heimat an
hilfsbereitschaft und durch wird
enthalte willen gesehen habe zeigt mir
dass unser land eine zukunft hat ich
danke allen landsleuten
den letzten monaten in meiner
heimatregion
großartiges geleistet haben sie sie
werden sehen wir bauen dieses land
wieder auf danke schön herr soweit
rüdiger luca sind von der af der liebe
zuschauer denn die zuschauer noch einmal
zum verständnis es handelt sich bei
diesem tagesordnungspunkt 2 um die
aufbauhilfe 2021 für die flutopfer damit
verbunden ist das infektionsschutzgesetz
dass wir sozusagen angehängt beide
gesetze haben wir im sachverhalt nichts
miteinander zu tun so kann man auch ein
kurzfristiges das vorhaben wie die
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
noch durch den bundestag bringen das
ganze nennt sich omnibus verfahren jetzt
andreas jung von der cdu/csu-fraktion
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
wenn wir heute über diesen
solidaritätsfonds
debattieren und ihnen dafür bin ich
überzeugt heute auch beschließen dann
sind wir in gedanken bei den opfern der
flutkatastrophe
wir sind in gedanken bei den angehörigen
bei den menschen in den dörfern in den
städten in den regionen und vierteilen
ihren schmerz und wir wissen geld kann
diesen schmerz nicht lindern aber
erinnern uns auch an das was wir gesagt
haben als er diese schrecklichen bilder
vor augen hat
wir werden euch nicht alleine lassen wir
werden euch nicht vergessen wo wir
helfen können wo bundesmittel nötig sind
wo wir mit bund und land und ländern
gemeinsam solidarisch unterstützen
können da werden wir es tun und dieses
versprechen lösen wir heute ein
[Applaus]
und wir lösen das ein mit einer großen
kraftanstrengung mit einem fonds der
geschält wird mit 30 milliarden euro den
bund und länder gemeinsam finanzieren
werden mit dem wir sagen
selbstverständlich dort wo
infrastrukturen des bundes betroffen
sind da werden wir die wiederaufbau aber
wo wir auch sagen da wo menschen in
ihrer existenz betroffen sind und
unterstützung brauchen da wo es um
betriebe und deren existenz geht da wo
in den gemeinden vereine einrichtungen
die dinge wieder aufgebaut werden müssen
da sind wir da und wir unterstützen und
wir sagen auch es muss schnell gehen da
muss keiner warten bis er den
zuwendungsbescheid hat es kann gleich
angefangen werden es muss unbürokratisch
sein und ich will ganz deutlich sagen
wir alle waren beeindruckt von dem
zusammenhalt in diesen gebieten und weit
über diese gebiete hinaus ich will sagen
respekt davor wie die menschen da
angepackt haben und ich will in unser
aller namen ein dankeschön sein an die
hilfsorganisation an die
rettungsorganisation an die polizei an
die feuerwehren an alle die dort
angepackt haben und mit gerufen es ist
eine grosse solidarische leistung
unseres landes
und selbstverständlich gilt dass wir
konsequenzen zu ziehen haben dass wir zu
fragen haben wo müssen wir besser werden
beim hochwasser schützen müssen wir
besser werden beim katastrophenschutz wo
müssen wir auch grenzüberschreitend
denken flüsse sind grenzüberschreitend
deshalb brauchen wir auch hier
grenzüberschreitende risikoanalysen
grenzüberschreitende vorsorgen
grenzüberschreitende strategien
grenzüberschreitende übungen wir müssen
hier im land und gemeinsam mit unseren
nachbarländern besser werden das wird
auch geld kosten dazu bekennen wir uns
es ist eine investition in unsere
gemeinsame sicherheit
und selbstverständlich müssen wir
schneller werden beim klimaschutz
dieses ereignis vor augen ist
unbestreitbar wir müssen den klimawandel
konsequent bekämpfen wir müssen hier
mehr tempo machen da kann man nie da
kann man näher ein einzelnes ereignissen
und ein aber es ist unbestreitbar sage
ich ihm her richtung ist unbestreitbar
und sagt die übergroße mehrheit der
wissenschaftler es gibt einen
menschengemachten klimawandel der führt
zu einer häufung von extremereignissen
darunter leiden viele regionen der welt
schon lange auch bei uns gibt es da eine
häufung und deshalb sind wir
aufgefordert entschieden zu handeln
und es ist nicht nur eine forderung es
ist gesetz wir haben die bundeskanzlerin
hat heute gesagt einen großen
fortschritt erreicht in dieser
legislaturperiode ein klimaschutzgesetz
gesetzlich verbindliche klimaziele
festgeschrieben werden sie nach geschäft
im juni klimaneutralität ist gesetz und
der pfad da hinten da gibt es kein
vertun da gibt es auch keine kompromisse
da ist vorgegeben jahr für jahr was
müssen wir erreichen das ist unser weg
den gehen wir konsequent an wir sitzen
dabei auf innovationen besitzen auch
planungs beschleunigungen wir setzen auf
ein turbo für erneuerbare energien wir
setzen auf neue technologien wie die
wasserstoff strategie und mit allen
maßnahmen mit einem instrumenten mix aus
regeln aus förderung starke förderung
zum beispiel für gebäudesanierung für
heizungs austausch für nachhaltige
mobilität und mit marktwirtschaftlichen
instrumenten werden wir das voranbringen
immer steht innovation im mittelpunkt
und immer steht im mittelpunkt dieser
zusammenhalt diese gemeinschaftlich
gerade beschrieben habe die brauchen wir
auch da und die brauchen wir auf der
ganzen strecke aber auf diesen ganzen
vater hin weil wir konsequenten
klimaschutz zusammenbringen mit
wirtschaft zusammenbringen mit sozialen
das ist nachhaltigkeit wir stehen für
nachhaltigkeit in der ganzen breite das
ist unser weg dafür haben wir wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen und die werden
wir beherzt angehen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
soweit jetzt andreas jung der ja nicht
nur stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender klima und energie
sondern diese funktion auch im zeit
neuesten im kompetenzteam bei armin
laschet hat nächster redner ist
ebenfalls stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender aber bei der fdp
wolfgang kubicki ersten redebeiträge
zeigt wie unsinnig die weigerung der
großen koalition war
die debatte über das sondervermögen und
die debatte über das
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht getrennt zu
behandeln sondern in einer gemeinsamen
beratung ich werde mich auch darauf
konzentrieren
zu redaktionsschluss zuletzt zu sprechen
den rest wird ihr kollege
fdp-fraktion machen um es kurz zu machen
meine fraktion wird der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes nicht zustimmen
nicht nur weil nach unserer auffassung
die pandemische lage nationaler
tragweite weder rechtlich noch
tatsächlich weiterhin gegeben ist diese
regierung lässt noch völlig im dunkeln
wann und unter welchen bedingungen der
bestehende ausnahmezustand beendet und
die normalität wiederhergestellt wird
nach unserer auffassung lassen sich
weitere massive grundrechts
einschränkungen nicht mehr begründen
war ende letzten jahres erzählt die
bundesregierung dass dann wenn alle
menschen in deutschland an die ems
angebote erhalten haben werden alle
grundrechts beschränkende maßnahmen
aufgehoben würden ich sah der
kanzleramtsminister helge braun anfang
märz und einen bemerkenswerten beitrag
gegenüber der funke mediengruppe
ausdrücklich wiederholt der einwand man
kannte die data bekannte noch nicht ist
nicht nur falsch sondern auch untauglich
dennoch ende juni hat das ärgert ihn in
seinem buch für alle festgestellt dass
spätestens im herbst wenn alle angebot
erhalten haben diejenigen die sich nicht
impfen lassen ausschließlich jene über
das krankheitsrisiko tragen wann also
enden die administrativen
eingriffsbefugnisse frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben heute morgen davon gesprochen
dass wir für die impfungen werden muss
dem schließe ich mich ausdrücklich an
jeder der die möglichkeit hat sollte
sich wirklich impfen lassen aber hören
sie auch nicht geimpfte zu bedrohen mit
dem ausschluss vom gesellschaftlichen
leben hören sie auf sie zu schuldigen zu
machen und ihre soziale verantwortung
infrage zu stellen das spaltet die
gesellschaft in unerträglicher weise
von nicht geimpften von nicht geimpften
geht keine gefahr aus von nicht geimpfte
keine gefahr aus die gefahr geht
ausschließlich von infizierten aus ich
habe mich impfen lassen vorletztes sind
keine angst mehr zu haben das sollte für
alle gesten gelten der virologe
christian drosten hat vor ein paar tagen
über dem ndr folgendes gesagt und hören
sie freundlicherweise zu mein ziel als
virologe drosten gehe ich jetzt gerne
immun werden will ich will eine
immunität haben und darauf aus datteln
will ich dann aber durchaus irgendwann
meine erste allgemeine infektion und die
zweite auch die dritte haben damit habe
ich mich schon lange abgefunden und dann
weiß ich bin ich richtig schlankheit ich
belastbar immun und werde nur noch alle
paar jahre überhaupt weil dieses virus
sehen genau wie ich die anderen kommunen
agieren auch noch mal wieder sehe zitat
ende es gibt infektion logisch sinn
weiterhin bei testungen zu bleiben weil
mittlerweile wissen dass auch geimpfte
und auch genesende infektionsträger also
ansteckend sein können dies sollte aber
den menschen frei gestellt sein und
nicht staatlich verordnet weil es ein
reines interesse des staates gibt das
pandemie geschehen im auge zu behalten
da es auch keine kostenpflicht bei
testen in jedem wissen macht übrigens
keinen sinn für die regus kleine
fraktion eine pandemische lage das und
ertrag bei der festzustellen und
anschließend testungen kostenpflichtig
zu machen das ist ein widerspruch in
sich
es wird zeit dass das prinzip der
eigenverantwortung wieder zum tragen
element unseres zusammenlebens wird wir
sollten dem beispiel unseren dänischen
freunde folgen und konsequent den weg
zur normalität gehen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner der ex partnerin nach
wie vor coop eg ist jetzt ebenfalls
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ihrer fraktion gesine lötzsch von der
fraktion die linke für die fraktion die
linke
herzen sagt frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir haben
ausreichend impfstoff wir haben
hervorragende biologinnen und biologen
ärzten krankenpfleger krankenschwestern
aber trotzdem erleben wir im augenblick
fast einen im stillstand da muss man
doch die bundesregierung fragen warum
schafft sie es nicht aus diesen
hervorragenden voraussetzungen etwas zu
machen ich glaube sie muss ihre
verantwortung endlich eingestehen meine
damen und herren endlich die bürgerinnen
und bürger geschnitten und heute nun für
die bundesregierung völlig überstürzt
nicht einmal eine anhörung im bundestag
wurde zugelassen und da muss ich ihnen
ausdrücklich widersprechen kollegen
dittmar völlig überstürzt die
verhältnisse zwischen arbeitgebern und
arbeitnehmern über den haufen werfen ich
sage ihnen arbeitsrecht und datenschutz
sind nicht so schönes wetter gerade in
krisen muss damit sorgfältig umgegangen
werden alles an wird zerstört vertrauen
und da machen wir die mit meinen lampen
und die virologen haben ja recht unsere
impfquote ist zu niedrig also müssen wir
über die frage sprechen warum pandemie
minister sparen mit seiner strategie es
gebe nicht geschafft hat sie hört zu
bringen zurzeit liegt sie bei 61,3
prozent nach aussagen des rk ii
vollständig geimpft man kann mir doch
nicht weismachen dass es in deutschland
fast 40% hardcore impfgegner gibt da
macht auch die bundesregierung etwas
falsch warum sind die fragen stellen in
dänemark schon 73 1 prozent und in
portugal 76 8 prozent geimpft haben sie
da mal nachgefragt einige fehler linie
auf der hand anfangs 2020 hat minister
sparen eine neue abteilung
gesundheitsschutz und sicherheit und
nachhaltigkeit gegründet als leiter
wurde ein general der bundeswehr berufen
der ausdrücklich auch in uniform
erscheinen sollte dort spätestens da
waren ja klar diese sache muss
schiefgehen ein virus kann doch nicht
mit militärischer logik besiegt werden
wir werden auch in zukunft keine kriege
gegen krankheiten gewinnen was wir
brauchen ist information aufklärung
überzeugung und dafür braucht man keine
generäle sondern psychologen
kommunikationsexperten also aufklärung
überzeugung gelegenheit keinen geredet
über krieg meine damen und herren
und es gibt auch ein misstrauen
gegenüber der pharmaindustrie die
preispolitik ist nicht transparent und
viele haben den eindruck dass es leiser
bei und tech und anderen im nicht nur um
die bekämpfung der pandemie sondern auch
um profite geht und auch dem müssen wir
uns deutlich entgegen stellen meine
damen und herren
was ist nun betrifft haben wir
historische vorbilder ich kann nur
empfehlen sich ein beispiel an elvis
presley zu nehmen 1956 ließ sich elvis
presley öffentlich vor einem auftritt
gegen polio offen danach explodierte die
modernisierung steht in den usa unter
teenagern in nur sechs monaten also wir
brauchen die richtigen vorbilder meine
damen und herren unsere botschaften sind
ganz klar
unausgegorene gesetzesänderung wie sie
hier vorliegen zerstören vertrauen
zwischen arbeitgebern und arbeitnehmern
das lehnen ja zweitens es muss jetzt
wieder nicht werden dafür brauchen wir
vertrauen glaubwürdigkeit und anreize
und der zugang muss niedrigschwellig
sein team ein beispiel in meinem
wahlkreis in berlin lichtenberg haben
wir hinter einem großen möbelhaus den
namen nenne ich jetzt nicht ein drais
und walking im zentrum errichtet da
kommen täglich hunderte menschen vorbei
das widerspricht doch der krieg der
these von der allgemein und müdigkeit es
muss mehr solche gelegenheiten geben das
wäre der richtige weg meinte
und
handeln besiegen wir nicht allein mit
impfstoffen sondern vor allen dingen mit
solidarität in unserem land und mit den
ländern die immer noch zu wenig
impfstoff haben und darum wiederhole ich
ganz deutlich unsere forderung geben sie
endlich die patente frei das ist eine
frage der solidarität aber eine frage
des selbst ich mein laden gehabt
jedoch kollegen wie gerecht ist wirklich
sehr ungünstig dass wir beide themen in
einem komplex behandeln müssen wir haben
in der vergangenen sitzung jahr und sehr
ausführlich damit befasst wie das
sondervermögen aufgebaut werden soll und
ich möchte für meine fraktion ganz
deutlich sagen wir unterstützen die
aufbauhilfen wir sind mit unseren
gedanken bei den menschen die so vieles
erlitten haben und wir bedanken uns
ausdrücklich bei allen helferinnen und
helfern und bei allen spenderinnen und
spendern da hat sich gezeigt dass es
unserem land bei den menschen viel
solidarität gibt
ihr müsst aber es müssen
wir brauchen endlich einen effektiven
hochwasserschutz und wir brauchen einen
wirksamen katastrophenschutz zu
beschließen wir wieder viel geld und
darum sage ich ganz deutlich wir wollen
vor der wahl wissen wer die rechnung
bezahlen soll
cdu/csu und fdp wollen vereinigen die
vermögenden nach der wahl steuerlich
entlasten und die wählerinnen und wähler
müssen wissen diese parteien sind die
vermögensverwalter der reichen in diesem
land und nicht die der mehrheit wir als
linke weil die 119 deutschen millionäre
zur kasse ja der milliardär ich
korrigiere mich zur kasse bitten keiner
von denen muss fürchten nach der von uns
eingeführten vermögensabgabe als ein
millionär sein leben fristen zu müssen
das versprechen wir wir wollen eine
gerechte gesellschaft wir treten an zu
eine andere steuerpolitik damit die
menschen in diesem land wieder besser
leben können herzlichen dank
nächster redner ist sind es deren kinder
von bündnis 90 die grünen hier ist der
haushaltspolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion in der verbundenen debatte über
die aufbauhilfe 2021 für flutopfer und
änderungen beim infektionsschutzgesetz
meine damen und herren am anfang dieser
debatte will ich auch feststellen dass
es ein unding ist und sehr unglücklich
dass wir die fluthilfe der wiederaufbau
frau und das infektionsschutzgesetz in
einem gesetz verbunden wurden die
gemeinsam diskutiert werden müssen das
ist für die parlamentarische debatte
sehr schwierig ich will sehr klar sagen
die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes halten wir
nicht für zielführend deswegen werden
wir sie ablehnen
am ende werden wir aber natürlich auch
dem wiederaufbau und den aufbau hilfen
zustimmen wenn das richtig und notwendig
ist wir danken allen rettungskräften die
auch in dieser schweren not geholfen
haben einen menschen die solidarisch
waren mit den menschen die so viel
verloren haben wo menschen viele
verletzt wurden viele menschen gestorben
sind viele zu viel verloren haben
deswegen ist es richtig notwendig dass
der bundestag gemeinsam mit den ländern
jetzt entweder auf walfang auf den weg
gibt und deswegen schon mit dem auch zu
aber wir müssen ja auch aus dieser
katastrophe lernen das heißt wir müssen
einen verbesserten katastrophenschutz
aufbauen und mehr koordination beim bund
aber die wissenschaft uns auch sehr
deutlich solche stark wetterereignisse
werden durch die klimakrise weiter
zunehmen und wenn sie an auftreten
werden die deutlich heftiger und das
zeigt uns ja auch mal an diesen tagen
und wochen im sommer dass wir so viel an
stark wetterereignissen gesehen haben
hitzewellen usa am kanada in
griechenland und italien in der türkei
in sibirien so viele weit brände das
grönland eis schmelzen wie noch nie also
wir sehen wir haben keine zeit zu
verlieren wir müssen jetzt denn jetzt
und nicht irgendwann des team geht es
bei der bundestagswahl darum dass wir
endlich ernst sache mit klimaschutz
das heißt auch dass die nächste
bundesregierung endlich ernst machen
muss mit klimaschutz denn savran denn
union spd in den letzten 16 jahren davon
hat 16 jahre die union regiert zwölf
jahren sammelte spd und haben sie
erneuerbaren energien rasiert der
fossile subvention mit milliarden
gepampert und sie haben dafür gesorgt
dass immer weiter neue autobahn gebaut
wurden sie haben nichts gemacht beim
klimaschutz und das muss sich endlich
ändern
und wenn man sich auch noch mal die
produktion der kandidaten von union spd
genau anschaut hat man da sehr viele
gemeinden übereinstimmung gegen
konkreten klimaschutz armin laschet und
olaf scholz wollen ein kohleausstieg
erst 20 38 olaf scholz und armin laschet
wollen weiterhin schmutzigen diese
subventionieren sie wollen weiter
milliarden für die flugindustrie
ausgeben sie waren weiter neue autobahn
mit milliarden dafür ausgeben statt das
geld in die bahn zu investieren olaf
scholz und armin laschet man könnte auch
sagen armin schulz und olaf laschet die
wollen weiter die klimakrise befeuern
dass es geht gar nicht wir müssen
endlich die ernte mit klimaschutz
warum ist jetzt geht brauchen jetzt
endlich einen großen aufbruch wir
brauchen mut für veränderungen den abbau
von klima fahren die subventionen große
investitionen statt im dogma der
schwarzen null und einen klaren
ordnungsrahmen für klimaschutz statt
weiter so mit der großen koalition
dankte
kindler von meiner seite noch eine
korrektur vor einigen nun habe ich
gesagt das muss man kubicki neben seiner
funktion als bundestags-vizepräsident
auch noch stellt der
fraktionsvorsitzende im bundestag sei
das stimmt nicht erstellt aus einer
parteivorsitzender der fdp
nächster redner johannes fechner von der
spd sprecher für recht und
verbraucherschutz
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer einen
starken staat der für die bürger da ist
den zeichnet es aus wenn er auch in
krisenzeiten wichtige entscheidungen für
die bürgerinnen und bürger trifft und
genau das machen wir hier und heute wir
beschließen wichtige ganz konkrete
hilfen für die hochwasser geschädigten
in rheinland pfalz sondern rein
westfalen und betreffen ganz wichtige
entscheidungen um die ausbreitung des
corona virus weiter einzudämmen und das
zeigt eines ganz genau wir die politik
wir sind handlungsfähig wir kümmern uns
um die bürgerinnen und bürger und
treffen für sie die notwendigen
entscheidungen so wie heute im bundestag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die schreckliche hochwasserkatastrophe
die hat uns alle erschüttert und
natürlich müssen wir in der nächsten
wahlperiode ganz genau prüfen welche
konsequenzen von bund und ländern aber
auch vor ort in den gemeinden und
kreisen für den katastrophenschutz
gezogen werden müssen und klar ist auch
dass für die betroffenen die 30
milliarden die wir heute hier zur
verfügung stellen eine ganz ganz
wichtige hilfe sind aber auch
rechtspolitisch machen wir einiges um
vor ort gerade die arbeitnehmer und die
unternehmen zu unterstützen denn wenn
arbeitnehmer und unternehmer ihr hab und
gut verloren haben dann sollen sie sich
nicht auch noch sorgen um den
arbeitsplatz und auch nicht um ihren
betrieb machen und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir als alternative zum
gang zum insolvenzgericht
die insolvenzantragspflicht aussetzen
und zwar bis august 22 um den
unternehmen luft zu geben wieder auf die
beine zu kommen eine ganz wichtige
maßnahmen regen und kollegen kollege
feld gestanden sie eine frage oder
bemerkung ist darauf die fraktionen nein
wir haben wieder ein hohes niveau der
debatte das wirklich nicht gefährden und
die hilfen sollen auch direkt bei den
unternehmen ankommen und deswegen nicht
dazu dienen alte forderungen von
gläubigern zu bedienen und auch das
regeln wir dass die hilfen schnell
ausgezahlt werden und vor allem dass sie
nicht weg gepfändet werden können
sondern den betrieben zur verfügung
stehen damit dort die jobs an denen ja
also auch die familien hängen dann auch
gesichert werden eine ganz wichtige
maßnahme liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und auch ich möchte an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich ein ganz großes dankeschön
und mein respekt gerade den
ehrenamtlichen helfern in den
hochwassergebieten ausdrücken das ist
wirklich großartig was dort geleistet
wird und einmal mehr regen ja im
bundestag nicht nur was ehrenamt und
zeigen zurecht unseren respekt sondern
wir unterstützen gerade die
ehrenamtlichen in den vereinen mit ganz
konkreten gesetzesänderungen zum
beispiel heute hier ich finde es wichtig
dass wir die online
mitgliederversammlungen für
mitgliederversammlung in den verein und
verlängern und viele weitere scheinbar
kleiner aber dann doch wichtige
verbesserungen und erleichterungen für
die vereine heute hier beschließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein wirklich
großer respekt für das ehrenamt und den
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind gerade
im vergleich mit den anderen ländern
etwa in europa gut durch die korona
pandemie gekommen das haben wir
engagierte pflegekräfte nerzen den
mitarbeitern mitarbeitern im
gesundheitsamt aber vor allem den
bürgerinnen und bürgern zu verdanken die
geduldig die zugegeben einschneidenden
corona maßnahmen eingehalten haben und
denen die sich geimpfte impfen lassen
haben aber gerade weil wir jetzt eine
hohe in tote haben können wir nicht nur
alleine auf den inzidenz wert abstellen
wenn wir prüfen ob eine so große gefahr
in der bevölkerung für die bevölkerung
besteht dass die erheblichen
grundrechtseingriff aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz tatsächlich noch
gerechtfertigt sind und deswegen ist es
gut dass wir heute ganz klar regeln dass
vor allem die hospitalisierung 's rat
also die auslastung in unseren
krankenhäusern entscheidend dafür ist ob
es noch einschneidende corona
schutzmaßnahmen es ist gut dass erspart
auch die union das will ich an der
stelle sagen hier eingelenkt haben wir
hätten das gerne schon im november
gemacht aber gut dass wir jetzt
wenigstens hier diese abkehr vom
incidents wert als alleinige kriterium
für die korona schutzmaßnahmen heute wir
beschließen können und das zeigt dass
wir als auch diese krone schutzmaßnahmen
daran ausrichten dass die grundrechte
der bürger geschützt sind dass der
verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz
eingehalten wird und vor allem dass alle
wesentlichen entscheidungen hier in der
volksvertretung hier vom bundestag
getroffen werden ist für mich eine ganz
wichtige feststellung liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
sowohl die korona pandemie als auch die
hochwasserkatastrophe ich komme zum
schluss haben uns gezeigt wie wichtig
ein starker staat ein starker
sozialstaat ist und ich glaube ihm
diesen gesetzen heute da zeigen wir dass
wir handlungsfähig sind und dass wir uns
um die bürgerinnen und bürger in der
krise kümmern vielen dank
nächster redner in der laufenden debatte
ist detlef spangenberg von der af der
sprecher der für gesundheit für die afg
hier im bundestag
das wort hat der abgeordnete detlef
spangenberg für die auf die frau zu
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin der damen und herren
schon wieder wollen sie die bürger
täuschen indem sie in ein
zustimmungsfähiges gesetz nämlich dass
fluthilfe gesetz schikanöse grundrechts
feindliche änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
einfügen
die schon wie schon in anderen fällen
zum beispiel war ein gesetz zur
verbesserung des schutzes von
gerichtsvollzieherin mai 21 das gesetz
zur vereinfachung des stiftungsrechts
juli 21 das gleiche spielen die
oppositionsparteien sollen durch diese
verknüpfungen von ganz unterschiedlichen
sachfragen gezwungen werden dinge
anzunehmen einen damen herren die die
oppositions verteidiger nicht annehmen
wollen das ist das ziel was sie hier uns
auf tragen diese diese unlautere weise
der koalition ist uns schon
parlamentarische übung geworden muss ich
leider sagen dazu kommt dass
änderungsanträge kollektionen
kurzfristig mittels eilends einberufene
ausschuss sondersitzungen eingebracht
werden so dass sie nicht ausgewertet und
beraten werden können dieses
widerspricht parlamentarischen
gepflogenheiten so zum beispiel die
letzte sitzung des ausschuss für
gesundheit am 29 wobei den
oppositionsfraktionen eine öffentliche
anhörung nach wie vor verweigert wird zu
den hier geplanten änderungen im
infektionsschutzgesetz im einzelnen ist
zu sagen auf 28 absatz 1 weiter
feststellen der über die mission lage
ist jetzt über die maske pflicht hinaus
die verpflichtung zur vorlage eines impf
gewesen oder test nachweises für
bestimmte inanspruchnahme von
grundrechten notwendig also die
einführung des sogenannten jährige meine
damen und herren es wird immer schlimmer
in diesem lande die abkehr
die abkehr in absatz 3 von den insolvenz
werten als alleiniger maßstab und
einbeziehung von versorgungskapazitäten
bei der beurteilung der situation ist
sinnvoll sie spricht den forderungen der
afd aber jetzt kommt das meine damen und
herren ab 7 kommt da eine sehr
bedenkliche änderung wurde schon
angedeutet hier wird nach ende der
feststellen der epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite die formulierung
dahingehend geändert dass für die
bundesländer die schwelle für kroner
maßnahmen fortgesetzt wird ehemals muss
es sich die krankheit ausbreiten
jetzt genügt schon die konkrete gefahr
einer ausbreitung das ist ein einfalltor
für subjektiv festgelegte grundrechts
einschränkungen die jeder nach belieben
für sich verwenden kann meine damen und
herren
eine weiter bedenkliche änderung in
paare auf 36 infektionsschutzgesetz
ermöglicht den arbeitgebern bestimmte
berufsgruppen
arbeitnehmer nach ihren impfstatus zu
befragen und entsprechend zu handeln hat
natürlich für arbeitgeber eine
wunderbare möglichkeit auch mal
unliebsame auf andere stellen innerhalb
des unternehmens oder ganz hinauswerfen
auch wenn es so zeigt nur bestimmte
berufsgruppen betrifft meine damen und
herren sagen wir wehret den anfängen für
auch zahlreiche bürger schreiben haben
sie bestimmt auch gekommen bedenken vom
deutschen gewerkschaftsbund und dem
datenschützer ulrich kleber die auch
hier wirklich große bedenken die
verschärfungen bei der einreise nach
paragraph nazi die frage regelung für
bürger aus dem schengen-raum die sie
auch eingeführt haben ist in dieser form
nicht nachvollziehbar da ja alle
europäischen staaten indische krone
maßnahmen vornehmen und jetzt in ihrer
aussage meine damen und herren die
freiwilligkeit der entscheidung über die
inanspruchnahme von impfschutz bleibt
unberührt
ist in unserer sicht eine leere
worthülse spricht holen
im zusammenhang mit grundrechts
einschränkungen gehen ungeimpfte
unterworfen sind dies ist einen
demokratischen staat unterricht vielen
dank
so wird der letzte spangenberg von der
afg
nächste redner von der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion und dort
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
stefan stracke in der verbundenen
beratung flutopfer hilfe und änderungen
beim infektionsschutzgesetz
präsidentin meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren nach 18 monaten corona
pandemie können wir sagen wir haben
dieses land gut beschützt
wir haben impfstoffe die wirken und
schützen und einer dieser impfstoffe
wurde in rekordzeit hier in deutschland
erforscht und entwickelt und wir können
gemeinsam stolz sein auf diesen
wissenschafts und forschungsstandort
deutschland der dieses fördert und
ermöglicht und nun gilt es deutschland
gut aus dieser pandemie zu führen dafür
ist das impfen weiterhin zentral wir
sind gut beim impfen wir haben genügend
impfstoff dafür haben wir als union
gesorgt und jede und jeder kann sich
sofort impfen lassen in diesem land aber
wir sind noch nicht gut genug um eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
verhindern die infektionszahlen bei den
ungeimpften sind mehr als zehn mal höher
als bei geimpften 90 prozent der kogit
patienten auf den intensivstationen sind
ungeimpfte und das zeigt impfen macht
den unterschied aus und deswegen will
tonen wir dies in diesen bereichen und
ich hab ja kubicki so ein bisschen den
eindruck sie haben drosten nicht
verstanden denn er ist derjenige der
deutlich gemacht hat er lässt sich im
weil er diesen basisschutz haben möchte
und das verändert die lage er geht damit
risikoloser in diese ins
infektionsgeschehen hinein und das macht
den unterschied in diesen bereichen
hinaus und nicht das wie sie es in
diesen bereichen auch tatsächlich
darstellen herr kubicki und wir werden
auch mit auffrischungsimpfungen den impf
erfolg absichern wir beginnen jetzt bei
den hochbegabten bei den
pflegebedürftigen mit den menschen die
auch eine besondere immunerkrankungen
haben das ist auch wichtig meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren seit der
beginn der korona pandemie war vor allem
der inzidenz wert ein wichtiger dieser
parameter hat ein stück weit an
bedeutung verloren durch den erfolg den
wir in diesem land haben deswegen macht
es viel sinn diesen nun als maßstab zu
ersetzen durch die hospitalisierung
incidents also durch die frage wie stark
sind unsere krankenhäuser in dem bereich
belastet das tun wir auch und wir setzen
neue maßstäbe
behalten allerdings die inzidenz als
einen master ab weiterhin weil er
wichtig ist für die betrachtung
desinfektions geschehens weiterhin und
den ländern obliegt es nun zu bestimmen
wie die schwellenwerte sind und wie die
art und weise des handelns in dem
bereich auch aussieht das ist
sachgerecht weil die
versorgungskapazitäten
regional sind weil sie überregional zum
teil organisiert sind wir sorgen damit
für mehr spielraum für die länder und
für passgenaue lösungen vor ort und auch
landesweit meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren einen lock down wird es nicht
mehr geben wir wollen durch diesen
kommenden herbst und winter kommen mit
impfen
hygienemasken und vor allem der 3g regel
bei den innenräumen und wenn jetzt davon
gesprochen wird dass das auskunftsrecht
des arbeitgebers etwas ist was
überstürzt wäre was gänzlich fremd wäre
dann darf ich zunächst einmal darauf
hinweisen dass wir seit längerer zeit
eine regelung im infektionsschutzgesetz
haben nämlich den 23a der genau für
krankenhäuser für reha einrichtungen für
teilweise von pflegediensten eine möbel
und arztpraxen die möglichkeit vorsieht
genau dies abzufragen nicht weil wir
sagen das macht in irgendeiner weise
einfach nur so weil es für die
arbeitsorganisation wichtiges für den
schutz der menschen entscheidend ist
dass wir das der arbeitgeber auch weiß
ob seine angestellten einen wieder im
status der angestellten in diesem
bereich tatsächlich ist und wir
übertragen und genau diese regelung in
ihrem kern auf die korona lage weitem
diesen ausweiten diese aus auf die
pflegedienste im stationären bereich
auch die mobilen pflegedienste
und natürlich auf kitas und schulen und
es macht doch sinn dass die arbeitgeber
ihre arbeitsorganisation darauf
abstellen können und hygienemaßnahmen
passgenauer treffen können ob ein
arbeitnehmer geimpft ist oder nicht und
genau deswegen zum schutz derer die
unseren schutz am meisten bedürfen die
jüngsten und die ältesten deswegen
machen wir diese regelung und wir
erfüllen damit auch unseren ethischen
auftrag unser land gut zu behüten und zu
beschützen ich bitte um zustimmung
so jetzt werden wir wahrscheinlich
wieder vom thema infektionsschutzgesetz
zum thema flutopfer kommen zumindestens
hat wolfgang kubicki vor hin dass
avisiert dass sein fraktionskollege
markus herbrand zu diesem thema hier im
bundestag referieren wird markus
herbrand ist auch mitglied im bundestags
finanzausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch mein
heimatort gemünd in der eifel ist durch
das hochwasser weitgehend zerstört
worden allein in meiner heimat kommune
haben in dieser nacht neun personen
infolge des hochwassers ihr leben
verloren und das es nicht deutlich mehr
waren ist ein großes wunder
und auch die materiellen schäden sind
apokalyptische
straßennetze ladengeschäfte kindergärten
schulen vereinshäuser sind ebenso
verloren wie ganz viele privathäuser
inklusive der darin befindlichen
lebenserinnerungen
viele haben dazu noch ihre arbeit
verloren die werkstatt des
handwerksmeisters das geschäft des
einzelhändlers restaurants hotels alles
weg alles zerstört alle die diese nacht
überlebt haben werden sie nicht
vergessen ich kenne viele menschen
persönlich die um ihr überleben gekämpft
haben und sicher noch jahre vielleicht
sogar ihr ganzes leben lang davon nicht
loslassen werden können zu dieser
verzweiflung gesellt sich aber auch sehr
große dankbarkeit dank für die
großartige hilfe organisiert durch
bundeswehr technisches hilfswerk viele
menschen landwirte unternehmen aus nah
und fern rotes kreuz die über viele
wochenenden und wochen kamen und auch
immer noch kommen um selbstlos zu helfen
und hierfür ist selbstverständlich auch
die solidarische hilfe von bund und
ländern notwendig bis heute ist
allerdings auch schon sehr viel zeit
vertan worden es wäre daher richtig
gewesen bereits früher eine
sondersitzung einzuberufen wie von uns
gefordert jeder tag früher an dem die
gewissheit darüber herrscht wie
finanziell entschädigt werden kann
entlastet diese menschen von
diesbezüglichen sorgen
um liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
auch die gelegenheit etwas nach vorne zu
schauen wir dürfen mit dem heutigen tag
keinesfalls zur tagesordnung übergehen
viele der betroffenen gebiete sind seit
jeher ohnehin eher strukturschwache wenn
wir jetzt nicht nachhaltig helfen
besteht die gefahr dass wir ganze
landstriche langfristig veröden deshalb
vier aspekte die mir wirklich wichtig
sind der erste punkt die hilfen müssen
jetzt wirklich unbürokratisch zeitnah
und nachhaltig kommen unser ziel muss es
sein den menschen eine langfristige
bleibt perspektive zu geben als
arbeitnehmer oder als arbeitgeber vor
ort der zweite punkt beim neuaufbau der
öffentlichen und privaten infrastruktur
darf ist keine bürokratischen hürden
oder denkverbote geben wir müssen die
chance jetzt nutzen um nicht nur den
status quo wieder herzustellen sondern
die regionen fit für die zukunft zu
machen durch die förderung
beispielsweise energie effizienter
heizungstechnik und modernen in einem in
einem modernen maschinenpark war den
unternehmen dann stellen wir weichen für
die zukunft zudem ist die anbindung der
ländlichen räume von grundlegender
bedeutung für die zukunft für das
zukünftige mit und nebeneinander von
stadt und land deshalb muss die
langfristig debattierte elektrifizierung
der eifel bahn von köln in die
betroffenen regionen ganz oben auf die
prioritätenliste der dritte punkt
wir müssen weiterhin lernen zukünftig
besser mit solchen katastrophen
umzugehen das reicht von den wahren
signalen ob digital oder analog bis hin
zur ausschöpfung der potenziale bei den
aufräumarbeiten
leider musste ich erleben dass hilfe vor
ort oft aus sehr formalen gründen nicht
geleistet werden konnte obwohl die
bundeswehr oder das technische hilfswerk
hochmotiviert schon vor ort waren auch
muss diese hilfe dringend über längere
zeiträume gewährt werden meines
erachtens zum teil über monate das
brauchen die menschen in den betroffenen
gebieten und viertens als letzter punkt
wir werden in den nächsten monaten
erleben dass weniger das geld sondern
mehr der fachkräftemangel vor ort zum
problem wird wir sollten deshalb auch
die ideen sammeln ich denke da
beispielsweise an ran sie haben jetzt
die zeit wieder kollege kubicki in übrig
gelassen hat aufgebraucht ist
wir sollten da ideen sammeln ich denke
da beispielsweise an
solidaritätsaktionen über die
handwerkskammern in ganz deutschland und
vielleicht darüber hinaus lassen sie uns
bitte gemeinsam nach vorne schauen und
den betroffenen gebieten nachhaltig
helfen herzlich hinter
gitter
so weit mag es werden von der fdp das
war der letzte redner der fdp in dieser
debatte jetzt folgt der letzte redner
der grünen oliver krischer er ist
ebenfalls
stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzende wie viele redner
vor ihm aus den verschiedenen fraktionen
in der heutigen debatte im bundestag
oder krischer
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich kann mich den wochen des
kollegen herbrand anschließend gemeinte
ist einer der orte wo es nach wie vor
apokalyptisch aussieht und das ist eine
riesige aufgabe und deshalb finde ich es
gut dass wir diese fluthilfe hier auf
den weg bringen dass wir diese 30
milliarden zur verfügung stellen umso
absurder es ist ein bisschen von der
großen koalition dass das jetzt mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz hier verknüpft
wird und eine merkwürdige debatte gibt
da hätten sie sich mal ein ruck geben
sollen ich glaube das wäre in die
betroffenen flutregion ein gutes signal
gewesen dass menschen die in
wahlkampfzeiten aussehen der deutsche
bundestag handels gemeinsam geführt
fertig gestaltete debatte sie will aber
auch sagen 30 milliarden die werden in
den regionen wirklich gebraucht da kann
ich mich nur anschließen das ist wichtig
aber die 30 milliarden sind längst nicht
das was notwendig ist da kommt noch viel
mehr oben drauf und wenn wir es nicht
schaffen aus dieser flutkatastrophe die
konsequenzen zu ziehen wenn wir jedes
zweite oder dritte jahr hier solche
pakete beschließen müssen oder noch
öfter dann wird dieses land das nicht
verkraften können mal ganz abgesehen von
dem menschlichen leid in zerstörung von
den existenzen und sonst noch wester
ansteht deshalb darf es nicht bei dieser
fluthilfe bleiben das ganze muss
konsequenzen haben in allen
politikbereichen meine damen und herren
und da bin ich ganz ehrlich sagen
da will ich ganz ehrlich sagen selbst
wenn man in der flutregion unterwegs ist
kann man da heute schon zweifel bekommen
die schöne stadt jülich weiß ein neues
gewerbegebiet aus in einer fläche und da
hat die flut noch nicht mal so richtig
schlimm zugeschlagen in einer fläche die
überflutet war mit freundlicher
unterstützung der landesregierung von
armin laschet da werden wir gerade nach
der flut jetzt die nächsten flut kosten
produziert und wenn wir daraus nicht
lernen wenn wir jetzt schon wieder so
weitermachen dann haben wir die
botschaft dieser flugkatastrophe nicht
verstanden meine damen und herren
und damit komme ich zu der frage des
klimaschutzes weil es ist ja richtig
solche ereignisse werden immer häufiger
und immer heftiger auftreten das ist die
eindeutige botschaft der wissenschaft
und liebe lieber kollege andreas jung
sie haben hier gerade gesagt das
klimaschutzgesetz ist das maß der dinge
nachdem sich das alles ausrichten möchte
dann würde ich aber darum bitten dass
auch nach danach gehandelt wird in
diesem klimaschutzgesetz ist für den
energiesektor ein emissionsbudget für
das jahr 2030 drin nachdem kann dieses
kohlekraftwerk in deutschland mehr
laufen darf wir haben aber heute morgen
hier gehört dass sowohl herr laschet als
auch herr scholz sagen
2038 kohleausstieg das soll weiterlaufen
sie halten sich heute schon vor der wahl
nicht an ihr eigenes klimaschutzgesetz
wer soll ihnen da abkaufen dass dies
nach der wahl meine damen und herren und
das muss anders werden und deshalb sage
ich zum schluss
dieses land dieses land deutschland kann
sich nicht länger eine regierung aus cdu
csu und spd leisten das muss sich ändern
das ist unbezahlbar ihre politik die sie
hier betreiben dankeschön ja so der
wunsch von oliver krischer cdu und csu
und spd sind alle gesetzten fraktionen
die noch zwei redner stellen der
laufenden debatte dass sie die letzten
drei redner zum thema fluthilfe und
infektionsschutzgesetz die nächste
rednerin ist nadine schön von der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion
die stellvertretende vorsitzende dort
unter anderem für familienpolitik und
digitale agenda zuständig nadine schön
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen kollegen eine thw helfer denn
aus meiner heimatgemeinde die wie so
viele andere in den flutgebieten in
diesem fall im aatal unterwegs war hat
mir erzählt dass sie eine
christbaumkugel aus diesem einsatz mit
nach hause gebracht hat eine
christbaumkugel die im morast im schlamm
lag neben vielen anderen und die
dramatik dieser ganzen flutkatastrophe
symbolisiert von einer sekunde auf die
anderen war die heile welt die so eine
christbaumkugel aus symbolisiert
zerstört
sachen die über generationen
jedes jahr in den familien gebrauchten
hochgehalten wurden waren weg schulen
spielplätze kindergarten alles was auch
das dorfleben die gemeinschaft vor ort
ausmacht war nicht mehr da dinge wurden
zerstört aber eben auch leben und
in dieser debatte wird deutlich dass wir
nach wie vor erschüttert sind und unser
tiefes mitgefühl ausdrücken für all das
was dort passiert ist wir bringen aber
heute mit dem aufbauhilfe gesetz auch
konkrete maßnahmen auf den weg um den
opfern zu helfen durch einen schnelleren
aufbau der infrastruktur durch bessere
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren durch
geld das dort dringend gebraucht wird
jetzt und in den nächsten jahren
wir schaffen darüber hinaus mit selbst
aus kaarst die grundlage für eine
bessere katastrophenwarnung in der
zukunft im flutgebiet natürlich aber
auch in der gesamten republik
und ich finde über dieses gesetz hinaus
müssen wir noch zwei weitere lehren aus
dieser katastrophe ziehen die erste ist
dass wir den zusammenhalt in unserem
land weiter stärken müssen und das ist
etwas was meiner fraktion sehr am herzen
liegt wo wir auch in dieser
legislaturperiode mit der ehrenamts
stiftungen mit vielen erleichterung für
ehrenamtler aktiv etwas dafür getan
haben dass wir diejenigen die nicht
fragen sondern direkt losfahren und
anpacken unterstützen und das war
wirklich beeindruckend weil sowohl die
hilfsorganisationen wie auch wie viele
privatleute einfach angepackt haben sie
sind hingefahren und haben geholfen ob
handwerker ob landwirte ob
privatpersonen und diese
selbstheilungskräfte der gesellschaft
dieses subsidiäre hans subsidiäre
handeln von der kleinen ebene die sich
selbst organisiert hat und in der ersten
sekunde schon handlungsfähig war das ist
wirklich beeindruckend und das müssen
wir stärken
und das
und so sehen wir als union auch den
staat nämlich subsidiär wir sind nicht
der meinung dass alles im bund
entschieden muss das alles zentral
geregelt muss dass einer für alle die
gleichen lösungen schaffen muss sondern
wir sind der meinung dass vor ort im
kleinen die besten die passgenauen
lösungen gefunden werden und dass wir
als staat als und die aufgabe haben
diese selbstheilung strukturen vor ort
zu starken den substituierten gedanken
zu stärken den staat denken vom kleinen
zum großen und das ist eine große
aufgabe auf fährt die nächsten jahre das
wir sowohl das ehrenamt wie den
zusammenhalt wie auf diesen subsidiären
gedanken des staates weiter stärken und
alle studien zeigen dass eine residenz
statt vor allem daneben präsident ist
wenn er diese dezentrale struktur hat
wenn er diese selbst heilungschancen
stark und auch das ist eine aufgabe für
die nächsten jahre wir müssen die art
und weise wie wir staat organisieren
überdenken und wir als fraktion haben
das angestoßen wir sagen wir brauchen
reformen in der art wie wir als stadt
wie wir als verwaltung die wir als
politik agieren wir können nicht so
weitermachen wie in den letzten 200
jahren sondern digitalisierung als
chance anders zu handeln und die
komplexen herausforderungen die wir
haben als
herausforderung zwingen uns dazu und
machen es nötig dass wir anders agieren
als bisher
und wir haben konkrete vorschläge auf
den tisch gelegt wie wird das machen
wollen ist in die einzige fraktion und
die einzige partei die bis ins detail in
ihrem wahlprogramm und den papieren
unserer fraktion beschrieben hat wie wir
den staat modernisieren digitalisierten
schneller flexibler und leistungsfähiger
machen soll
und darauf hat es in den nächsten jahren
ankommen es geht nicht immer nur um mehr
geld sondern es geht um strukturelle
änderungen wir haben die vorschläge auf
den tisch gelegt und genau die wollen
wir umsetzen damit das was in dieser
flut passiert ist dass wir teilweise
zwischen den ebenen zu langsam war zu
schwerfällig waren nicht mehr passiert
damit wir wirklich will ist residenzen
in der krise aber auch für die großen
komplexen herausforderungen unserer zeit
und dann haben wir die richtigen lehren
aus dieser krise gezogen und das ist
unsere aufgabe für die nächsten jahre
ist soweit nadine schönen von der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion die vorletzte
rednerinnen und gleichzeitig die letzte
rädern aus der spd-fraktion laufen
debatte ist claudia moll sie ist
mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
claudia moll von der spd die vorletzte
rednerin
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
nicht einmal acht wochen ist es her dass
sich für viele menschen alles änderte
zehntausende verloren ihr haus ihr
geschäft ihre existenzgrundlage
183 menschen verloren ihr leben
nichts wird für ihre angehörigen jemals
wieder so sein wie zuvor
auch in meiner heimat der städteregion
aachen wütete das hochwasser ich habe
die bilder
der zerstörung noch vor augen bilder aus
eschweiler stolberg und roetgen bilder
der zerstörten dörfer und städte
wie kleine bäche zu reißenden flüssen
wurden wie das wasser ganze straßen
überflutete geschäfte und wohngebäude
komplett verwüstet wurden ich werde die
bilder von meinem zerstörten krankenhaus
und die verzweiflung in den gesichtern
der menschen nicht vergessen ein älteres
ehepaar erzählte mir dass ihr haus in
dem sie all die jahre lebten komplett
zerstört ist sie haben sich auf ihren
lebensabend gefreut und müssen sich nun
eine neue bleibe suchen menschen in
einem alter die auch nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg vor dem nichts standen ich
werde auch nie wieder diesen gestand
vergessen den gestank von schlamm öl
benzin und fäkalien doch statt
ohnmächtig zu beobachten wie das
hochwasser unsere heimat zerstörte zogen
die menschen die gummistiefel an
krempelten die arme hoch lehrten keller
und gebäude und befreiten diese von
schlamm und geröll
ich war begeistert als ich gesehen aber
die landwirte und unternehmer schweres
gerät bereitgestellt haben um all den
schutt wegzuräumen
ohne geld ohne gegenleistung
vor ort um das ganz deutschland ist uns
eine enorme solidarität entgegen
gekommen menschen fuhren hunderte
kilometer bewaffnet mit schaufel
schneeschiebern und bau trocknen um zu
helfen und sie erzählte mir wie gerührt
sie waren das die menschen die so schwer
getroffen waren sich auch noch um sie
kümmerten und selbst hilfsbereit zu
ihren helfern waren der zusammenhalt war
und ist unglaublich das ist gelebte
nächstenliebe und verdient großen
respekt
obwohl den schmier und kaffee ausgeben
spenden sortieren oder wasser abfüllen
bis heute wird unglaubliches geleistet
um die menschen zu versorgen und zu
mindestens ein stück normalität
zurückzubringen die menschen in den
betroffenen gebieten lassen sich nicht
unterkriegen
sie haben jetzt vor allem 1 redlich
verdient liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
hoffnung die hoffnung darauf
dass ihr ihre dörfer und städte wieder
ihre heimat werden das ist ein bisschen
wie früher vor der katastrophe wird
lassen sie uns heute im deutschen
bundestag ein stückchen hoffnung geben
einer der hoffnung gibt es olaf scholz
kollegen 0 gestatten sie eine frage oder
beratung auf tiefe zu von weg
aus der auf die frau zu quark schneien
ich bin unserem finanzminister dankbar
dankbar dass er früh in die
hochwassergebiete gekommen ist in meiner
heimat und er hat die richtigen worte
gefunden
er sagte das leid die verluste die
schrecklichen erinnerungen können wir
nicht ungeschehen machen aber was wir
mit geld ersetzen können das werden wir
mit geld ersetzen und das ist das
versprechen um das es geht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin daher froh dass wir heute über
30 milliarden abstimmen werden 30
milliarden euro weil wir es als
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe sehen um
eben nicht regionen und länder alleine
lassen 30 milliarden mit denen wir
unsere städte unsere gemeinden unsere
heimat wieder aufbauen werden aber nicht
nur häuser straßen und brücken sind
zerstört
auch arbeitsplätze sind gefährdet
das wird oft vergessen
olaf scholz hat deshalb zu recht
betriebsräten gewerkschaften und
geschäftsführern regionaler firmen
zugesichert dass wir es nicht zulassen
dass durch das hochwasser arbeitsplätze
verloren gehen und sie auf unsere hilfe
zählen können
die katastrophe ist für uns noch nicht
vorbei auch wenn einige keller trocken
und das geröll teilweise beiseite
geräumt ist stehen wir vor zerstörten
laden zahlen wohnhäusern straßen und
brücken machen wir uns nichts vor der
wiederaufbau wird lange dauern und kraft
nerven und vor allem aber geld kosten
wichtig ist dass das geld über die
soforthilfe hinaus schnell und
unkompliziert kommen muss bund und
länder müssen sich auf hilfen mit
möglichst wenig bürokratie und kurzen
verfahren einigen wir dürfen die
hoffnungen die wir heute geben nicht
durch vorschriften und auflagen
zerstören liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie uns hoffnung geben hoffnung
geben für die menschen die vor ihren
zerstörten häusern stehen die nicht
wissen wann ihre kinder wieder in die
dorfschule gehen können die nicht wissen
ob sie jemals wieder in ihr haus können
ihren laden eröffnen können und die
nicht wissen wann ihr normales leben
zurückkehrt ich danke ihnen
der nächste und letzte der laufenden
debatte ist thorsten frei von der cdu
csu bundestags fraktion
entschuldigt da kommt jetzt noch eine
wenn die direktion in deutschland ein
impfangebot haben gibt es rechtlich und
politisch keine rechtfertigung mehr für
irgendeine einschränkung dass sagte erst
am 6 juli diesen jahres ihr
spd-minister heiko maas das
bundesgesundheitsministerium sagt das
schon zum siebten juni die priorisierung
aufgehoben wurde und jedem in
deutschland ein impfangebot gemacht
werden kann wie kann es dann sein dass
heute auf initiative der spd weitere
einschränkungen beschlossen werden und
wie glaubwürdig ist die spd wenn die
worte ihrer minister nicht mal ein paar
wochen lang geltung haben
möchten sie erwidern dann haben sie das
wort
hört es sich an wie vorher die rednerin
claudia moll kunde es blieb
die auf eine antwort verzichtet sie
erfahren in der debatte fort das wort
hat der kollege thorsten frei thorsten
zwei von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
für innen recht und verbraucherschutz
ist der letzte redner der laufenden
partie und wahrscheinlich der letzte
redner in dieser legislaturperiode im
bundestag jedenfalls einem regulären
gesetzgebungsverfahren thorsten zwei
sidentin liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
in der nacht zum 15 juli
war das ein unglaubliches und lange bis
dahin nicht dagewesenes starkregen
ereignis das ganze teile des urteils und
der eifel zerstört hat und viele von
ihnen werden die bilder auch noch im
kopf haben die verzweifelten gesichter
die schäden die an kriegsgebiete
erinnert haben und wenn wir heute ein
großes aufbauhilfe gesetz im volumen von
30 milliarden euro beschließen dann ist
es nicht nur eine gewaltige
wirtschaftliche hilfestellung ist es vor
allen dingen ein zeichen der solidarität
mit dieser landschaft mit dieser region
und mit den menschen die dort leben und
so schlimm zu liken hatten und haben und
dass wir uns das leisten können 30
milliarden wiederaufbauhilfe dass wir
uns das leisten konnten die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie mit
300 milliarden euro auszugleichen das
ist die leistung einer haushalts- und
finanzpolitik dieser bundesregierung in
den vergangenen zehn jahren
liebe frau lötzsch sie haben gefragt sie
wollen vor der wahl wissen wie die
rechnung bezahlt wird ich kann es ihnen
sagen zwischen 2014 und 2020 haben wir
jedes jahr ausgeglichene haushalte
gehabt diese solidität in der
finanzpolitik ist die grundlage dafür
dass wir solche herausforderungen
bewältigen können und die entfesselung
der wirtschaft wird es uns auch in
zukunft ermöglichen diese kosten zu
bezahlen und wieder auszugleichen wir
setzen auf entfesselung und nicht
umgekehrt auf knebelung der menschen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
auch weitere maßnahmen neben dem geld
ergriffen beispielsweise die aussetzung
der insolvenzantragspflicht und ich bin
froh die bundesregierung und des
bundesjustizministerium hat es bis
oktober vorgeschlagen ziemlich weltfremd
um ehrlich zu sein denn in der jetzigen
situation geht es ja nicht darum dass
man irgendwelche rechnungsbelege aus dem
schlamm rekonstruiert in der jetzigen
situation geht es ums nackte überleben
von betrieben dem schutz von
arbeitsplätzen und deswegen war es der
vorschlag von armin laschet diese
regelung bis ende januar des nächsten
jahres mit verlängerungsoption zu machen
damit man die prioritäten richtig setzen
kann damit man das einen nach dem
anderen tun kann damit man den menschen
die luft zum atmen gibt das war der
vorschlag von armin laschet wir setzen
es heute um
und ich fand es sehr bemerkenswert was
hier gesagt worden ist zu der zweiten
großen krise und herausforderung die wir
parallel zu bewerkstelligen haben den
weg raus aus der corvette 19 pandemie
und deswegen lieber herr kubicki habe
ich das wirklich auch nicht so ganz
verstanden was sie in ihrer rede gesagt
haben denn wir setzen heute etwas
gesetzlich um was wir in der vergangenen
sitzungswoche postuliert haben und das
alleine ist kein eingriff in grundrechte
das was wir heute machen mit der
änderung des paragraphen 28
der weg aus der pandemie heraus wir
schaffen mehr freiheit mehr
möglichkeiten und das machen wir
verantwortungsvoll weil wir reagieren
auf die situation weil wir sagen die
neue infektions incidents die sagt zwar
etwas über die dynamik aus und die es
gewaltig am 28 juni hatten wir 431
neuinfektionen heute haben wir 14.000
täglich das ist der unterschied kollege
und ich habe ihn nur angehalten und
gestatten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
des kollegen ja selbstverständlich
herr kollege frei
ich habe den kollegen kubicki verstanden
und möchte das noch mal an sie fragen
warum gibt es keine kostenlosen
antikörper tests mit antikörper tests
wenn sie kostenlos ausgegeben werden
haben sie zwar nicht mehr die kontrolle
bekommen die antikörper her um bemerkt
genesene vielleicht auch publikum welche
anderen impfstoffe auch immer aber sie
haben antikörper und antikörper in einer
gewissen menge sind ausreichend eine
neue infektionen dem krankheitsausbruch
auch erheblich zu beeinflussen und
letzte frage sie haben die finanzpolitik
so gepriesen des bundes dich der
städtetag die gemeinde nächten auf dem
letzten loch es sind die warnsysteme
die eingesparten bahnsysteme die
feuerwehren die eben auch in der
bedrängnis waren bei der überschwemmung
wäre es nicht an der zeit das loblied
über die vergangenheit etwas kritischer
zu sehen um mit zukunft mehr in die
warnsysteme bei einer solchen
überschwemmungskatastrophe zu setzen
zwei zwischenfragen des abgeordneten ezb
jetzt von der fraktion die linke zwei
fragen beantworten zum ersten jahr haben
genügend möglichkeiten zum schutz und
zur immunisierung jeder hat die
möglichkeit und die gelegenheit sich
impfen zu lassen wer das nicht möchte
hat die möglichkeit sich testen zu
lassen und dann am gesellschaftlichen
leben auch mit anderen auch mit jenen
die er nicht kennt entsprechend
teilhaben zu können die zweite frage die
sie gestellt haben möchte ich ihnen auch
gerne beantworten wir im letzten
jahrzehnt ein jahrzehnt der rekord
steuereinnahmen gehabt jedes jahr höhere
steuereinnahmen als im jahr zuvor und
das galt nicht nur für den bund das galt
auch für die länder und es galt auch für
die kommunen die kommunen haben
investitions haushalte wie lange zuvor
nicht gehabt und deswegen ist es an der
aufgabe jeder politischen ebene seine
aufgaben entsprechend zu bewältigen und
im bereich des katastrophenschutzes
ist die zuordnung der zuständigkeit in
unserer verfassung so dass sie den
ländern und den kommunen zugeordnet ist
und viele kriegen das ja auch ganz
hervorragend hin und der bund
unterstützt es deswegen haben wir
beispielsweise waren apps deswegen haben
wir jetzt beispielsweise auch in der
analogen alarmierung 1 88 millionen euro
programm aufgelegt um sirenen zu machen
wir hatten mal 80.000 funktionstüchtige
sirenen in deutschland heute sind es
15.000 das war nicht der bund der zu
einer solchen entwicklung geführt hat
sondern es waren die kommunen die diese
sirenen abgebaut haben wir unterstützen
sie jetzt dass sie sie wieder
ertüchtigen und aufbauen können wir
investieren in das zelt kaste in meine
kollegin schön hat das erwähnt um
sozusagen den teppich an warnsystemen
dichter zu geben und damit den schutz
der bevölkerung weiter zu verbessern das
ändert aber nichts daran dass es eine
eigene originäre zuständigkeit des
bundes in der katastrophenhilfe nicht
gibt dass es die verfassungsrechtliche
lage sollte man auch zur kenntnis nehmen
kollegen style aber noch immer die uhr
angehalten ich habe jetzt noch zwei
meldungen bin aber gehalten dafür zu
sorgen dass sich ihre redebeitrag nicht
verdoppelt oder verdreifacht
ich habe eine meldung des kollegen
kubicki zu einer frage oder bemerkung
und ich habe eine meldung des
abgeordneten
kleinwächter lassen sie diese noch zu
schaffen sie es dann wenn beide das
hintereinander weg gemacht haben
gemeinsam zu beantworten gut dann bitte
frage von wolfgang kubicki von der fdp
fraktion
herr kollege frei dass sie mich nicht
verstanden haben habe ich an die
ausführung festgestellt ist er versucht
zu erklären worum es mir geht mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz der mobileo märz
letzten jahres hat der gesetzgeber die
idee verfolgt eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern jetzt
steht darin eine erhebliche belastung
des gesundheitssystems die idee war und
ist dennoch wenn alle wohlhabenden
gruppen und die älteren zu denen ich
auch gehöre geimpft sind jeweils mit
einer quote bei ungefähr 85 prozent dann
besteht keine gefahr mehr dass das
gesundheitssystem belastet würde weil
die jüngeren jahrgänge selbst wenn sie
infiziert sind werden sie infiziert sie
nur einen schwachen verlauf waren wenn
sie überhaupt symptome zeigen je jünger
desto weniger intensiv das ist die idee
der denen die vor acht wochen genau dem
gefolgt sind und erklärt wir haben alle
über 50 je und soweit sie wollten
geimpft deshalb können wir alle
maßnahmen aufheben jetzt zum 10 alle
maßnahmen auf bei klar ist das
gesundheitssystem kann ich überlastet
werden und die spannende frage steht im
raum warum machen wir das nicht in
gleicher weise wo ist die sorge die sie
haben und das ist vielleicht was
passiert der deutschen forfait erklären
müssen wann ist denn der punkt erreicht
von dem sie sagen
wir höher mit allen maßnahmen auf wenn
alle 0 bis zwölfjährige impft sind oder
wie soll ich mir das vorstellen
der abgeordnete kleinwächter hat noch
das wort und
segelflieger ist der zweite frage
norbert klein richter von der stift
meine einschätzung nach beantwortet
haben nämlich nach den antikörper tests
was ist das für eine strategie die sie
erfahren dass sie grundsätzlich gesunden
menschen die sich keine impfung gegeben
haben misstrauen gleichzeitig
privilegien ausstellen wollen für
diejenigen die geimpft oder genesen sind
und dann aber gleichzeitig einen
medizinischen indikator der uns eine
relativ verlässliche aussage darüber
gibt ob sich jemand noch mal re
infizieren kann und ob in diesem fall
eine starke infektiosität ein
besorgniserregender krankheitsverlauf
auftreten kann dass sie diese
medizinischen hinweise negieren ein
solcher medizinischer hinweis ist in der
tat das vorliegen von neutralisierenden
antikörper test das kann im labor
durchgeführt werden weshalb negieren sie
die existenz dieser tests und binden sie
überhaupt nicht in die entsprechende
corona strategie der bundesregierung ein
warum lassen sie menschen die beweisen
können dass sie antikörper haben dass
sie keine gefahr für die gesundheit sind
komplett abblitzen und stellen sie im
prinzip in einen eine diskriminierte
position zusammen mit all denen die
ohnehin gesund sind und jetzt sich mit
tests qualifizieren müssen am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilzunehmen
warum keine kostenlosen test warum
überhaupt tests zur teilnahme an der
gesellschaft das ist diskriminierend und
es ist vor allem medizinisch nicht
angezeigt
sie haben das wort zur antwort
geschätzter herr kollege
kubicki bei allem respekt aber sie haben
mich ja nach einer gesundheitlichen
frage und gefragt und haben eine eigene
einschätzung gegeben ich würde ihnen
jetzt in gesundheits politischer
hinsicht höchstens ein bisschen mehr
vertrauen als der bundesaußenminister
aber ich würde mich nicht darauf
verlassen und deswegen will ich ihnen
ganz klar sagen natürlich haben wir
menschen in unserer gesellschaft die
sich nicht impfen lassen können dazu
gehören beispielsweise schwangere dazu
gehören bestimmte krankheitsindikationen
und dazu gehören auch neun millionen
kinder unter zwölf jahren von denen ich
diese pauschale aussage dass sie
ungefährdet sind in dieser situation und
eine durchseuchung völlig
unproblematisch wäre
unverantwortlich finde und deswegen
schließe ich mich dem ausdrücklich nicht
an
und herr klein rechter ich kann einfach
nur noch mal das gleiche wiederholen es
gibt eine umfassende schutzstrategie es
gibt unterschiedliche möglichkeiten wie
man das machen kann und wie man darlegen
kann dass man nicht infektiös ist das
ganze ist immer auch eine frage von
ressourcen eine frage von geld gegeben
allein für testungen milliardenbeträge
in diesem jahr aus und deswegen glaube
ich ist es sinnvoll sich hier auch
entsprechend zu konzentrieren lassen sie
mich einen letzten damit wirklich am
ende der fragen lassen sie mich einen
letzten punkt machen an dieser stelle
wir haben in diesem gesetz auch deutlich
gemacht dass es ein fragerecht des
arbeitgebers geben muss beispielsweise
in seniorenheimen in kitas in schulen
dass wir es nicht geschafft haben das
auch auf andere arbeitgeber zu
übertragen finde ich sehr sehr
bedauerlich ich will nur an einem
beispiel demonstrieren was es bedeutet
gehen sie als gast in ein restaurant
dann müssen sie geimpft sein dann müssen
sie getestet sein aber der gleiche wird
darf seinen koch und seine kellner nicht
fragen ob die impfte oder getestet ist
das ist doch eine absurdität überhaupt
nicht zu überbieten und deswegen finde
ich schlimm dass wir das allein deshalb
nicht hingekriegt haben weil die
gewerkschaften dagegen waren mitglieder
der politik sollten das schlussmachen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]